vu étonné parce qu il en manque un
pardon de vous couper il encore qu'un
c'est donc toute l'année dernière on a
ces vos disques favoris
il ya une parole qui est rentré dans le
larousse vous n'êtes pas au courant de
ça balawi clamoux la gare la moue la
gare où la gare c'est rentrer dans la
vie elle est où la voulez vous la grosse
houle ou alors j'aime bien j'ai un gros
jeu avec mes enfants alors je vais genre
je suis très énervé thierry chauvet
aller où ouais les enfants vous l'avez
bisous jeu je n'ai pas aimé quoi et on
rigole comme dinars dans une fosse qu'à
l'académie française en pas ce qu'ils
cherchent de la rentrée des mots ils ont
en moyenne 87 ans d'âge moyen il met la
blague à my son my vivent avec leur
temps mais qui prennent ou six poules où
m'avez-vous lost et ya huit ans c'était
à nice castet à trois ans mercy mais
bien évolué avec le temps bien sûr
apparemment lui n'a pas évolué un voile
a eu les chéris tiens j'ai une autre
pique au rad
d'ancienneté chez jeff bezos ce sera le
premier trio nerveux l'histoire bezos à
me lire mille milliards de dollars c'est
le montant que pourrait atteindre la
formule de jeff bezos c'est le patron
d'amazon en 2026 monde est content ou
pas il a déjà bon là il à 143 milliards
de dollars 133 milliards d'euros
franchement ça représente le pib de 180
pays voici où fin est très chiant s'en
rend compte qu'on n'a pas acheté de
tee-shirts
mais c'est un précédent 180 pays le pib
de 180 pays et son ex femme est rentrée
directement dans le classement des
hommes les plus au ras des femmes les
plus riches du monde ce qui a touché 26
milliards de dollars c'est incroyable du
morse c'est fou mais on est content ou
pas elle veille à questa fait dans la
vie j'ai divorcé et voilà voilà